[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sally welt
heute beginnt auf meinem kanal der
ramadan monat beziehungsweise die
ramadan saison
der ramadan monat fängt nächste woche an
und das ist der fastenmonat der muslime
auf einem kanal und in meiner app und
auf meinem blog findet ihr bereits ganz
viele rezepte dazu der ramadan monat das
deckt praktisch 30 tage da wird den tag
über gefastet abends gibt es dann das
fastenbrechen und abends darf man auch
wieder essen und trinken zu sich nehmen
auf einem kanal findet er wie gesagt
schon einige rezepte heute möchte ich
mit was süßung starten
und was ich dieses jahr auch machen
werde weil man ja morgens bis zu einer
bestimmten uhrzeit nur essen darf bis
sonnenaufgang habe ich mir gedacht ich
finde ich es morgen sowieso immer ganz
gut wenn man müsli ist oder porridge
oder haferbrei weil das einfach den tag
über sat hält wo man so ganz viele
nährstoffe ballaststoffe und vitamine zu
sich nehmen kann und deswegen gibt es
auf meinem kanal bzw in meiner app
einfach in der kategorie porridge noch
weitere frühstücks ideen die auch abends
vom vorbereiten könnt und einfach
morgens essen könnt und habt einfach was
gesundes leckeres für den start in den
tag also da könnt ihr auf jeden fall
vorbei schauen und in der ramadan
kategorie sind auch ganz viele rezepte
verlinkt heute starte ich in diesem jahr
mit einem süßen rezept nämlich mit einem
pistazien milch kuchen weil pistazien
eigentlich schon was sehr orientalisches
türkisches auch sind es wird ganz oft
benutzt ich weiß dass in deutschland
viele bis dahin nicht so oft benutzen
aber es ist was wirklich sehr leckeres
man muss auto zu sagen sie sind relativ
teuer deswegen benutze ich da jetzt auch
keine 200 gramm davon in einem rezept
sondern geht schon sparsam damit um
aber das aroma ist einfach sehr lecker
heute starte ich jetzt hier mit dem
rührkuchen dafür nehme ich vier eier 100
gramm zucker eine prise salz und etwas
vanille extrakt jeweils 50 gramm
pistazien und man denn die sind bereits
gehäutet 100 gramm mehl und einen halben
teelöffel backpulver den ofen habe ich
jetzt bereits auf 170 grad ober
unterhitze vorgeheizt ich werde den
kuchen gleich rund backen weil ich es
einfach schöner finde aber wenn ihr sagt
zum ramadan möchte denen gerne eckig
haben dann könnt ihr auch die umrechnung
funktion in meinem blog internet
benutzen
denn dann könnt ihr jede form also egal
ob ein großes blech oder nur eine kleine
form einfach oben rechnen lassen und vor
allem im ramadan kann man schöne kleine
kuchenstücke servieren
gerade abends so als dessert finde ich
das doch ganz gut jetzt nehmt ihr zuerst
die einkommen in die rührschüssel da ist
nur wichtig dass die zimmer warm sind da
hat sie sich gleich besser aufschlagen
lassen dann zucker salz und vanille
extrakt dazu und dann dürft ihr diese
masse etwa fünf bis zehn minuten schön
cremig verrühren und ich werde in der
zwischenzeit die mandeln und pistazien
hacko bei den pistazien und mandeln ist
es so die mandeln habe ich jetzt ohne
haut ohne diese braune haut ausnahme
falls ihr die so nicht bekommt könnt ihr
auch die mit haut nehmen oder übergießt
die einfach mit kochendem wasser lassen
zehn minuten stehen und dann könnt ihr
die haut ganz einfach so aussehen und
dann können das ja auch fein hacken
[Musik]
so soll die zuckermasse dann aussehen
die eier zucker so schön dick cremig und
hier habe ich jetzt bereits backpulver
und milch vermischt
ich kann die zutaten kurz dazu sieben
dann kurz unterheben
das ist einfach jetzt ein ganz normaler
biscuit ich nehme jetzt hier einfach
mein lochblech mit einem back ring den
ich auf 22 cm eingestellt habe und jetzt
kann ich hier die mandeln und staat sind
auf den boden streuen dann habe ich so
einen knusper boden
und dann kommt jetzt hier den master
drauf mit glatt gestrichen und dann kann
der kuchen gebacken werden und ich kann
in der zwischenzeit mich schon mal um
die pistazien menschen kümmern
für die pistazien milch nämlich 70 gramm
pistazien 250 gramm zucker und 205 sagen
was sie jetzt zuerst machen werde
ich nehme etwa die hälfte der milch und
glück in den mixer gibt da die pistazien
dafür da kann ich die nicht darin
pürieren und die übrige milch gebe ich
in den topf und gebt den zucker dazu
damit er sich auflösen kann
jetzt einfach kurz aufkochen lassen und
bisschen rühren damit sich das schöne
ist dass ich muss sagen die bis dahin
milch hilft jetzt schon sehr lecker ich
hab da kochen wird echt gut und hier
könnt ihr theoretisch die pistazien mit
einfach schon mal auskratzen und susanne
geben denn diese zutaten werde ich gar
nicht mitkochen
dann kühlt auch die zucker menschen
schon ein bisschen schneller ab
das sieht man dann auch schon ganz gut
dass der zucker sich gelöst hat
die spüle damit jetzt nur noch kurz den
mixer aus damit die pistazien da nicht
verschwendet werden
ich mags ist einmal kurz durch und dann
habe ich wirklich schön alle reste und
kann dann die milch abkühlen lassen
wenn ihr wollt dass depp starts in
kuchen so richtig schön grün ist dürft
ihr auch gerne noch ein bisschen
lebensmittelfarbe dazu geben
ich finde wenn man jetzt so viel bis
dahin nimmt dass der kuchen ganz grün
wird wird's halt schon mächtig teuer
deswegen könnte da wo ich mit
lebensmittelfarbe nachhelfen oder ihr
sagt ihr belastet einfach bei der
natürlichen farben
[Musik]
dann las ich das abkühlen den kuchen
fertig backen und dann geht es gleich
weiter
ich glaube da machen wir uns jetzt noch
ein smoothie
[Musik]
der kuchen ist gebacken ich habe jetzt
praktisch eine stäbchen probe gemacht
und wenn dann nichts mehr dran hängt
dann ist er perfekt jetzt werde ich den
kuchen aber noch ein stechen das könnte
jetzt auch mit einem zahnstocher
schaschlikspieß mit einer gabel machen
wobei eine gabel nicht ganz so gut
geeignet ist da man mit der nicht bis
ganz nach unten kommt deswegen lieber so
ein kuchen tester oder einen
schaschlikspieß und jetzt hier ein
bisschen einstechen und dann geht er
milch übergießen
[Musik]
dadurch rühren und dann am besten am
rand anfangen und langsam übergießen und
das lasse ich das erst mal kurz
einziehen und gehst dann noch eine
schicht darüber dass ungefähr 100
milliliter lasse jetzt übrig wenn jetzt
alles rein gehst dann bildet sich in der
mitte so eine coole deswegen kurz warten
bis es einzieht und dann nochmal drüber
gießen und zum servieren lassen wir da
noch was übrig
[Musik]
die pistazien milch ist jetzt gut in den
kuchen eingezogen ich habe das ganze in
den kühlschrank gestellt damit auch
schön kalt wird jetzt kann ich hier
schon mal die sahne creme zu bereiten da
mache ich jetzt meine quark sahne
ihr könnt aber auch eine joghurt sahne
machen oder was mit frischkäse zu
bereiten wichtig ist nur dass es jetzt
nicht sooo süß wird denn die pistazien
milch war ja auch schon leicht gesüßt
dafür nämlich 250 gramm quark 50 gramm
puderzucker eine limette davon koch ich
den abrieb 200 gramm sahne und etwas
seiner partei das könnt ihr direkt hier
den kragen die rührschüssel geben dann
den puderzucker dazu und schlitten
abrieb da bitte darauf achten dass es
limetten sind deren schale man mit wird
sein kann steht meist drauf unbehandelt
oder schale zum verzehr geeignet denn
bio heißt auch nicht immer gleich
ungespritzt davon nämlich gar nicht zu
viel sondern wirklich nur einen hauch
dann kurz berühren die sahne zugießen
und mit seiner park steif schlagen
[Musik]
hans volker rath runterschalten beim
sahne sollten
[Musik]
den kuchen sehe ich jetzt hier auf einen
torten retter dann könnt ihr den
tortenring lösen lustig habt ihr noch
fragen schon gelöst ich habe mich
dasselbe verraten kann den lösen aber
wieder drumherum spannung und das was
hier auf der oberfläche sind praktisch
die zerkleinerten pistazien und ein
bisschen rest sahne und ich habe noch
ein bisschen was im behälter aufbewahrt
jetzt noch die folie darunter weg jetzt
kommt hier die trotten creme drauf dann
können die schön verstreichen entweder
weil ich oder in die mitte gleich mit
einer palette
das zeige ich euch gleich in der mitte
mit einer palette ein schönes muster
ziehe aber wenn ihr wollt könnt ist auch
so einfach will ich machen dass das
kleine spitzen hoch gucken wo ihr könnt
auch einen spritzbeutel nehmen
ursprünglich war dass sogar mein plan
aber jetzt nicht mehr
ich nehme jetzt so eine kleine palette
ihr könnt auch einen löffel oder ein
messer nehmen dann in der mitte ansetzen
und nach außen ziehen
ich habe es hier nochmal gehackten
pistazien die streu ich hier an den rand
der aus ist und so die spirale entlang
aber da muss man sehr präzise arbeiten
dass man sich noch erkennt und wenn ihr
möchtet gerne noch essbare blüten die
finde ich passen hier ganz gut dazu
[Musik]
ich geb dir essbaren blüten und die
nehme ich ganz oft für salate oder eben
auch für gepäck die geben dem ganzen so
ein schönes aroma weil sie einfach
wunderbar nach nach blüten richten die
torte ist jetzt im prinzip fertig ich
werde sie allerdings noch kühl stellen
müssen für mindestens zwei stunden am
besten aber auch über nacht so mache ich
zu setzen oder probieren wir morgen
direkt die torte ich denke sie mit einem
trocken retter einfach ab
[Musik]
jetzt ist das erste diesjährige ramadan
rezept fertig morales atrium auf der
baustelle
deswegen würde ich sagen darf unsere
hobby thürkind ob sarah pasta den
mixtape ich sag's doch die türken oder
ich habe nicht so schön
ich bin da auch da ist schön geworden
der richter auch so gut ich finde ich
doch richtig blumig man richtig richtig
gut aus ich habe auch noch
ich habe auch noch von der milch was da
also man kann auch noch auf den teller
ich hab so dass der kuchen bislang wird
schön dann auch das klingt so blühten
die ja auch so machen wir das gleiche
wie unser serviervorschlag voll
zwischen untertitel für unsere videos
aufnehmen wolle so günter gesprächsthema
ist ein konto das musste ich gar nicht
mehr hat einen kran spuren
[Gelächter]
ich dachte jetzt kommt das zitrone drin
das ist lecker oder schmeckt richtig
nach frühling ich hatte kurz vergessen
wie ich die creme gemacht habe aber dann
zieht es nun wieder einen ja die ist
richtig man sofort sehr fruchtig ich
muss sagen dieser pistazien milch ist
nicht so gut eingezogen wie bei den
thriller liegt wohl daran dass die
pistazien einfach zu groß sind
aber ich finde es so jetzt gar nicht
schlimm weil ich finde die soße kann
also falls er diese torte gerne mal
ausprobieren wollt so sieht sie von
innen aus dann schaut gerne auf sallys -
blog.de vorbei oder in meiner app da
findet ihr auch rezepte wie gesagt
könnte den kuchen rund oder eckig machen
eckig als schnitte ist ja auch hübsch
grundschüler jahrhundert orten die sind
schon immer schönere mac ich es halt
einfacher zu portionieren weil man dann
wirklich auch mal ganz kleines stückchen
machen gerade auch von den kleines stück
außerhalb abends vielleicht nach dem
fastenbrechen dann großes stück ok zara
zara ein großes stück also wie gesagt
dieses rezept viele weitere findet ihr
in meiner app ich wünsche euch viel spaß
beim nachbacken probiert die torte gerne
mal aus und sagt mir dann wie solch
geschmeckt hat bis zur nächsten wahl
oder spricht eigentlich nichts sagen
heil wird am sonntag um den ramadan
monats praktisch so gesegneten ramadan
damals
update außen auf jeden
[Musik]